Now that we have everything set up so that we can use the ocean lake and river tools,
let's take a look at each one of the tools individually starting with the ocean tool.
Now to add the ocean tool to any of our projects, all we need to do is go up to the quickly
add and type in the word ocean and then click or drag the water body ocean into the map.
Once we do that, we're going to get something that looks similar to this.
So let's go over here to the editor and do this now.
Inside of the editor, we're going to come up here to our quickly add.
We're going to look for ocean and then we're going to do our water body ocean like so.
This insert new landscape edit layer.
This is telling us where do we want to put this layer in relation to our other landscape layers.
For us, we just have the single water, so we're going to leave it as default and hit complete.
And when we do that, there we go.
We have got our landscape here with our water and site of it.
Now, one of the things that we do need to do is move this over.
We always want to make sure that the spline that you're seeing here that represents our landscape area
is inside of the landscape actor itself.
If it goes outside of the landscape actor, you're going to see that issue that we just had.
One of the other things I like to do just to make sure that there are no issues is just zero out the X and the Y.
Now, we can adjust the landscape's height.
We can push it down and things like that.
The other thing we can do is we can adjust these little spline points right here to adjust the look.
And feel of the landscape.
And now if we right click on one of them, we can add a spline point like so, so that we can actually kind of rough around the shape of our landscape here.
To look kind of similar to something that we are trying to achieve.
Now, there are a couple of ways that we can adjust the way that the landscape and the water intersect with one another.
Underneath the ocean itself, you're going to find a terrain and a water height map settings.
Now, every single water actor that you are going to encounter are going to have these settings and they all work in a very, very similar manner.
What we can do those for is first, let me just pop over here to the editor really quick.
What we can do is first we can come over here and if we go to our curve settings, the first one is adjusting how the landscape
and the water intersect with one another.
So if I take this channel depth here and I put this really shallow, what this is going to do is this is going to give us a very, very shallow entry into the water,
much like you would find at a beach.
If I take this number and I increase it really, really high, it's going to make that drop off really, really, really steep, much like you would find it.
Maybe the ocean and the cliff and notice the waves as well.
The waves will actually react to the channel depth.
So the sharper that drop off is, the steeper the waves are going to be, the shallower that drop off, the more shallow those waves are going to be.
And you can see here, it actually does kind of have a shallow waves here towards the beach.
And then as it gets deeper, the waves get more and more intense.
The next area that we're going to adjust is going to be the terrain settings, which can help us give a more natural look to our our landscape just by editing a few parameters.
So this was actually achieved by just editing the curl noise and falloff settings.
So if we come back over here to the editor, let me just zoom out so we can see stuff a little bit better.
So the curve settings under here, under this part of the train are going to affect the water and the beach interaction.
The height map settings that we have over here are going to affect this as a whole.
And if we come over here to effects and we do something like a curl noise and we do something like a point one, two, five, maybe we do like a little bit more here.
We can get some start to get some really cool effects.
But just be aware that the more intense the numbers that we put in here, you know, if we were to put in like something like 16, we're going to get some really, really, really crazy results.
Just keep that in mind that lower numbers tend to work a little bit better here.
Now, one of the other things that you might encounter is having the landscape water not intersecting or creating a little bit of a hole with your terrain.
And the easiest thing to do that is to either grab your landscape spline points and move them in so that the water occupies that area or just add a few more spline points by simply right clicking on them and adding a point here and then finessing that point so that the water mesh will go up against the landscape.
And there won't be this missing piece of water.
Now, again, this only happens when you start to really push the editing inside of the landscape in the water body ocean here and under the terrain settings, the water height map.
If we start to push the effects like our curl noise very high, that's when we're going to start to see some of these artifacting.
Now, there is one other thing that I want to talk about and that is the LOD.
Now, by default, it is going to have the LOD on.
Older versions of Unreal did have this defaulting to off.
And what this level of detail actually does is it makes sure that the most active or the highest concentration of the simulation for the water is happening at the shore and closest to the camera.
And then after a certain point, it's going to go to a completely flat static mesh that is much cheaper to render.
And in order to adjust that, if we click on our water zone down and rendering under our far distance, we're going to see this far distance mesh extent.
And this is going to allow us to push that far distance mesh really far back into the distance or bring it up closer should we want to do that.
Now, again, by default, it's set to, I think, 400,000 here.
So you're probably not going to need to adjust this, but it is something that is nice to know about in case you need to adjust it for a future project or something of that nature.